okay so rarely is sort of am i lucky
enough to get to like put the main
theorem on the first slide but here's
like which is bad actually for everyone
coming in late but ok so here here's the
main result any polynomial size in your
program for macs cut has integrality gap
of a half for max to set as integral a
gap of three fourths and for say max
three set eyes integral yep seven
eighths this is the main result so let
me just point out that these are the
integrality gaps achieved by the most
standard basic LP that you would write
down on day one for these problems these
are also the approximation ratios you
would achieve by just random assignment
to the to the variables in the case of
max reset bye-bye Johan's where we know
it NP hard to approximate within seven
eighths so in particular p is not equal
to NP it implies this result but this
will be unconditional and and then also
for Mexican and Max to said we know that
actually Gomez Williamson get something
better than half and three-fourths right
so this shows that I mean there's a
simple quadratic size semi definite
program for instance for max cut that
achieves much better than half but any
polynomial size in your program can do
at most at best a half and okay and
actually this holds not just for
polynomial size but lower bounds of n to
the log in approximately on the size of
linear program I didn't tell you what a
linear program is obviously because
there's we didn't prove peas Nigel NP so
there's some caviar okay and the main
technique is a maybe a bit surprising
initially that for max constraint
satisfaction problems actually
polynomial sizing your programs are
exactly as powerful as a constant number
of rounds of the charlie adams hierarchy
so and then of course all these bounds
follow because we know very strong
bounds for Charlie apples yeah so are
you
yes so we'll get to it soon so so in
particular in particular it's known that
linear programming is P complete under
sort of various notions of reduction so
if you could really prove this for any
linear program then you would be saying
that NP doesn't have polynomial size
circuits but on the other hand I mean am
I solving maxed up by linear programming
if I first reduce it to we using my
magical reduction to weighted bipartite
matching and then use an LP for weighted
bipartite matching I mean he probably
wouldn't call this linear program and so
of course we have to be more specific it
had a log in but it was completely
unrelated to this I yeah it's a good
problem we can talk about it but it's a
song yes somewhat unrelated okay so let
me tell you about the a very incomplete
history of linear programming lower
bounds they basically come in sort of to
two strains one is work on these
specific linear programming hierarchies
like the lava shriver lift and projector
key or charlie adams and this this sort
of considering these sort of
systematically for approximation
problems this was really kicked off by
row below passion low last in 2002
trying to understand what are the
integrality gaps for increasingly more
sophisticated linear programs and just
as a reference point and everything i
say these LP hierarchies they have
realms and as you increase number of
rounds of course they become tighter and
tighter until I ten rounds they they
really equal the integral hall but you
should think about the are around
relaxation at size n to the order of our
this is how to compare rounds and size
so what do we know here we know lots of
things there's been a lot of work let me
just focus on max cut so we know that
max cut has an integral account of half
so the shine back Jeff asansol siani
proved that in lova shriver for a linear
number of rounds the gap is still a half
I should mention it charlie adams is
strictly stronger than low bus driver so
results for lower bounds first rally
atoms are stronger than the last shriver
fernandes de la Vega and Matthew prove
that any constant number of rounds of
charlie adams has
has a gap of half from max cut and I'm
then after that char karmakar Jed
McCrory chav actually proved that end to
the epsilon rounds Australia I'm still
hasn't the girl yet with half there are
some quantifiers their right to get half
plus epsilon you have a lower bound
against n to the C of Epsilon okay but
rounds but actually very quite strong
lower bounds so this is this is one
model where we have actually very kind
of strong lower bounds for very specific
families of linear programs and then
there is this other line of work based
on extended formulations that was
started by iana caucus in the 80s where
he showed I'll say what this means in a
second that every symmetric linear
program 40 HP has exponential size as it
has to have at least exponential size
and also so the same thing for perfect
matching okay and then it was open
whether and not the symmetry assumption
was it was necessary and very recently
in this beautiful work of the arena at
all they actually showed that any
polynomial size in your program
relaxation for PSP has size at least 2
to the root n okay so let me tell you in
this setting what the linear programming
relaxation means so here's the idea of
an extended formulation you have some
polytope in RN okay which is possibly
very complicated so for the case of tsp
this will be the convex hull of all the
integral tours of the complete graph ok
so it's known that this thing is very
complicated in a sense that it has about
you need like end n factorial defining
inequalities sort of to get this
polytope it has many many facets and in
particular that makes it difficult at
least using standard techniques to
optimize over it because it's very
complicated pollito so what you could
hope to do is the following you could
hope that you increase the dimension to
some n some big n which is bigger than
the little lamb little lamb and then
it's increased to mention you find this
much simpler pollito ok simple here is
in terms of the number of facets and
then and then if you were if you're
clever maybe you can you can show that
this simple values will be it linearly
projects to the much more complicated
polytope in low dimensions and then
actually it would be in great shape
because if you can optimize over this
pollito you can actually can optimize
over this polytope as well so so if
there exists a a polytope with
polynomial many facets that projects the
th peter polytope then you would
apollon with em algorithm for tsp ok so
this result shows that any polytope that
projects the TSP polytope has a size at
least two to the root n and actually you
can think of it equivalently of you you
take sort of the standard LP 4 TSP and
then you can add some more variables
right you can add a polynomial number
variables and you hope that when you add
these variables the number of
constraints you need to specify the
polytope will drop dramatically and it's
not completely an academic discussion
because say for spanning trees it's
known that the spanning tree polytope
has actually exponentially many facets
and yet there is an extended formulation
of size n cubed for spanning trees so if
you look at spanning geez on the
complete graph there is a way to add n
cube new variables to the basic linear
program so the number of constraints
becomes polynomial ok so that's so that
that's this model here and and then
recently sort of these results were
extended to show that approximating
click within end to the half minus
epsilon requires linear programs besides
2 to the N to the epsilon and then
Braverman moitra got this actually now n
to the 1 minus epsilon approximation
requires 2 to the N to the epsilon so
what I want to stress is first of all
you have very strong results in sort of
it for specific LPS and somewhat weaker
result for this very kind of beautiful
general notion of an extended
formulation and and here we actually you
know the the lower bound examples are
very sophisticated they random graphs or
geometric constructions or things coming
from extremal combinatorics here you
know sort of the this paper made this
amazing discovery that basically the cut
polytope contains inside it some matrix
related to this set to join this problem
and then actually that discovery was
using all three of these results so sort
of it's a singular point you don't
really know how to move out from there
so so what do we like to do today is
sort of be able to prove these kind of
strong lower bounds in this general
framework and then more and then more
than that of course it allows us now to
use these very sophisticated
constructions to argue there so it sort
of expands the class of examples we can
use to talk about general linear
programs ok so now let's uh let's get to
you vault question about what is a
linear program and I think it's a very
satisfactory answer but please you know
object if you feel like some moral
urging like this is a travesty against
humankind okay so first what is max cut
you have a graph and you have a subset
and then this function cut of s this is
the fraction of edges that cross the
subset in the graph okay remember that
because this function will come up a lot
in the natok so cut gia signs to a set
the fraction of edges crossing it and
then the max cut the optimal value here
is just the maximum over all the cuts of
the cut value of the of the subset okay
so suppose we wanted to write that on in
your program what's the standard thing
you do first you right now max cut at
say a quadratic program okay and then
you say well I can't have products xixj
a linear program so I linearized a spire
by having some variable that represents
this product okay so for instance here
suppose I want to introduce variables y
IJ that represent 1 minus xixj over 2 ok
ok so then so then the objective
function becomes maximizing the sum of
these why I James over all the edges so
okay so this is sort of what one step in
designing your program is linearizing
your objective function ok and then the
second step is now that you have a
linearized objective function you have a
polytope to optimize over right so okay
so you now you can start adding in any
inequalities that are true for for your
original integral variables you can add
them in the most obvious one is that the
YJ should be between 0 and 1 you can
start to get more clever you notice it
on every triangle a cut can cut at most
two edges so you throw those cuts into
the LP you notice it in every triangle a
cut can cut it cannot cut exactly one
edge so you throw that into an LP the LP
and then of course you can get you know
you can now you're on a roll right
somehow you say oh actually for a five
cycles I can cut at most four of the
edges I can keep going and of course the
whole idea of these linear programming
hierarchies or the extended formulations
is to somehow automate this process so
that it's not like every day we're
wondering if you just add one more
constraint can you suddenly solve the
problem much better ok so this is ok so
this is the standard relaxation now what
do I mean by linear program I want to
have two steps the first one is the
linearization of the objective function
so for every input size n
we are going to be working it will have
some number n which is the number of
dimensions of the relaxation and then we
have the following for every graph we
have a vector corresponding to the graph
for every cut we have a vector
corresponding to the cut and then here's
the and this is the linearization it
should be that if I take the inner
product of the graph vector with the cut
vector it's the cut value ok this is
what i mean by linearizing the objective
function ok so that's the so you can you
can take any vectors you want any for
the graph any vector is you want for the
cut but they should satisfy the fact
that you actually get the correct thing
on the integral solutions and then you
just need some polytope and the
requirement is that the polytope
contains all the integral points ok so
that's a linear program you have a you
you have a some vectors for graphs some
vectors for cuts and a polytope
specifying you know that contains all
the all the integral points ok and then
the value the lp value is just right the
maximum over the polytope of the inner
product with the graph and then and the
size of the relaxation is the number of
inequalities you need to specify the
polytope so this is a number of facets
of the polytope ok so this is the model
it's a non-uniform model of computation
because for every end you have a gather
different possible relaxation right and
I mean the real constraint here is that
so if you think about it what you can do
is do you think about the input graph is
just a complete graph and then I and
then later I give you the weights so the
real constraint air is that the polytope
is not allowed to depend on the weights
of the graph right it's I I know it's
not like I give you the graph and then
the polytope can contain can sort of
here contain some inequalities depending
on what weights you put there ok but
that's kind of what people mean by
linear programming like you you give me
you know i have a polytope and then you
give me the weights and i optimize the
weight function ok ok so this is what
one web we mean by linear program is
anybody object on ok I mean in
particular for it for like maxi ESPYs
all the relaxations for LPS nasty
people's try to use they look like this
yeah
the same for all you don't even a number
of vertices uh yeah so you can think
about the graph is just being the
complete graph and but it probably was
the same for all the weight functions
you give me as input yeah and this is
necessary if you yeah divergence from
what you're doing but you could have an
exponential size of your program with an
inclusive algorithm for solving rapidly
yeah so called generation Jimmy right so
this doesn't rule out like ellipse with
having a having a separation Oracle and
using lip sort algorithm this is yeah
this this sort of kind of rules out
interior point methods that depend on
the number of facets or or as a
combinatorial problem just rules out the
existence of these small relaxations but
the skirt this is true it's so framed
for the perfect matching problem of
course we have a polynomial time
algorithm based on an exponential size
linear program that uses ellipsoid and
we don't know it's still open whether or
not there's a polynomial size linear
program for matching non non bipartite
matching
ice pollito represent Roxas Yeah right
then then things seem to get very could
do it very very hard but it's aight i
mean this yet so this doesn't rule out
in your programming for matching we know
it approach base something your
programming even though we don't know of
any small linear program and in fact in
a caucus conjecture there isn't any
small linear program for matching but we
don't know the answer to that okay so
that's a no controlling your program
what's the notion of approximation will
save the relaxation is a CS
approximation if whenever the the max
cutting the graph has died at most s the
linear program tells you the device that
most see ya so there is there seems to
be an inherent weakness of this extended
formulation if you believe with their
permission to know where easy this is
very hard so there is something i mean
we actually don't know it first are
spanning tree for sense but indications
are then this is what's happened so as a
methodology this is team used to this
still leaves something to be desired
sure we will again there will always be
something to be decided right and you
make small steps there's a geesee is to
make an order which doesn't get your
finger
right and this one I mean this extended
formulations as projections of polytopes
is just beautiful the idea right okay so
so so they to CS approximation whenever
the optimal that is at most as the LP
can prove to you its at most see and
what you should think of here for max
car is that in the hard instances the
graph will basically have s being about
half plus epsilon so every cut cuts only
about half the edges but the LP will try
to claim that there it's that graph is
almost by part type that there's a cut
cutting almost all the edges that will
give this factor to gap for Mexico okay
so now how are we going to prove lower
bounds it seems like a very general
model okay come back the second so the
point is uh yeah Jana caucus gave this
beautiful framework for proofing lower
bounds for extended formulations so one
thing you have to be willing to do is
whenever you see a cut you have to be
able to associate it with the
corresponding boolean vector so I'm
going to switch from talking about you
know this was a function on cuts now
it's going to be a function on boolean
vectors where the the cut is this the
cut defined by everything that which is
equal to one and everything which is
equal to minus one ok so now here's a
Jana caucus is a characterization if you
have an LP relaxation of size are that's
a CS approximation then you have these
non negative functions q1 up to Q sub
are on the hypercube such that whenever
the optimal value is at most s there
exists non-negative weights such that
okay so this is a this is inequality of
functions so here but here this function
i means c is the constant function this
is a function that assigns to cuts the
fraction of edges across them and then
this is one this is the sum of these
functions so what this is saying is that
the LP is trying to prove that the vac
the the value of the maximum cut is at
most see so this is saying the only way
you can do this is first before it finds
out the graph to give you these
functions and then it has to be that now
for any graph it can put the c minus the
cut value into this cone spanned by the
QRS right so this is in particular proof
right this equality constitutes a proof
that the maximum cut drives are most
because the the right hand value is not
negative so it's constitutes a proof
that c- cut is great equal to 0 and the
the claim of the theorem is that
actually this is the only kind of proof
the LP can give all right and actually
here's the here's the proof of the this
take your take your linear program so
you maximize your objective function
over some polytope with our constraints
and then what are the q is the Q is are
just going to be the slack function so
okay so I have a bunch of constraints so
now for the ice constraint i define this
function qi x so we know that our
polytope contains all the integral
points so for every you can test for
dive constraint against the well the
integral point concours mine is like uh
Tess you can look at how much slack is
there this is the this is the function
Qi Qi again Qi is a funky on the
hypercube but for consistency i'm making
a function on sets right here in the
next slide the sets will go away
everything will be functions on the
hypercube so now what does Farkas lemma
tell us it tells us that any linear
inequality that's valid for this
polytope has to be actually a non
negative linear combination of the unit
updating the qualities i define the
polytope so if the LP has value at most
see then it means that this inequality
is true this is the same thing as saying
the LP over the polytope p and therefore
Farkas says that we can write this as a
non-negative combination of these things
with that exactly gives us a
representation notice that if I if I put
a cut vector here then it's exactly c
minus the cut side so that exactly gives
us our representation from the theorem
so this is just Farkas lemma restated
and it's if and only if you can it's a
really a characterization of one there
exists a linear program rack sational
size are okay uh okay good so now I want
to prove lower bounds against these
things so how does one prove a lower
bound well the LP gives me this cone of
functions so what do I need to do when I
get it well I need to find a graph G and
then I need to prove that this point is
not in this cone so I can do that with
the I mean there's only one way to do it
by finding a separating hyperplane
between the point and the cone so this
is the idea for the lower bound the LP
gives me this
these functions that give me a scone
then I find a point outside and a
hyperplane proving that the grass is not
in this con ok and in fact we're going
to do it in a sort of special form will
find the hyper so here I said HSI
hyperplane age is really the normal
vector to the hyperplane but we'll find
an H such that the inner product with
all the Qi is is greater than equal to 0
and the inner product with C minus the
cout function is less than zero and then
this will prove you know this will prove
that this inequality convince equality
cannot hold my just by taking enterprise
with both sides okay so I want to stress
two things here first of all right H is
just a function on my per cube okay call
it a hyperplane but it's a think about
as a function on the hypercube and and
the second thing is you notice that I
mean if you look at this there's no
there's no room for error here this was
zero and this was zero which always
makes me I mean you know I'm listen to a
talk uncomfortable because i have i have
no idea how people even start to prove
equality's but the but the point I mean
so the point here is though that if you
think about the suppose I have sort of
some kind of setup like this if I
decrease the completeness value so I'm
trying to prove a lower bound say where
C is 1 minus epsilon if I increase this
to 1 minus 2 epsilon then actually I can
get some slack in this hyperplane this
inequality becomes more negative so
there will be some noise which starts to
arise in the proof and you can wonder
the noise seems to you know be bad for
this kind of setup but by barring a
little from the completeness we can
always make the hyperplane bit fatter
okay all right so so now I told you how
we're gonna prove a lower bound and I
said we're gonna use the charlie adams
hierarchy so what is trolley adams so in
this set up Charlie items actually has a
very beautiful clean description here's
the definition we've seen already a
function is AK hunter if the function
depends on only k of its input
coordinates and now shirali adams 4k
rounds corresponds exactly to this setup
where the functions can be any
non-negative que juntos okay so in other
words sure all the atoms 4k rounds is
the cs approximation if and only if for
every for you know if and only said
let's say sir all atoms 4k rounds proves
that
the optimum is a most see if and only if
i can write this function as a
non-negative combination of non- que
juntos ok so actually I the sort of just
I would specify here it's not clear I
could I could need quite a large number
of hunters I mean right it could be an
infinite number of points in this
culinary to use one thing Charlie Adam's
proved is that actually so still it
suffice it's only these n to the order K
functions to do this area to get this
expression but we don't need that will
just need the fact that Charlie Adam's
corresponds to K hunters and i'll come
back to that at the end but sorry that's
our starting point okay so here's the
okay so now we're jumping into the proof
okay yeah strengthening of our custard
or is it that general what do you mean
so first you focus gave that it's non
negative you can write it as negative
combination
seems to say which part did this theorem
should I the other was a lousy this is
it to search yeah so yeah so it sure
sure and in fact it's equivalent so the
best sort of way that you can express
things like this using now I don't give
you a bounded number of functions you
can use as many function as you want but
your functions have to be local so this
is exactly equivalent to Charlie items
ok so now okay so now we want to use a
sure all the items gap to prove a gap in
general so let's take g0 to be some gap
instance so the you know the optimal
value of G 0 is at most s but k rounds
of charlie adams thinks that the album's
i was bigger than C right so again think
about the like this graph has max cut
off by about half but shirali annum
stinks that claims that the graph has
max cut near one okay so what do we know
we know from this that if I that that
there is a hyperplane separating this
function course went to g0 from the cone
of all them now negative juntas this is
just what I said on the previous slide
we will will we so actually you can give
this hyperplane explicitly and we'll
need to use a couple properties the
hyperplane you won't just be able to use
this existence but this is what we have
to work with we have a hyperplane that
separates some hard grab g0 from all the
non negative que juntos ok so let's say
the size of g0 is M and now we're going
to do is you want to select slowly build
up the class of functions we can handle
at the moment we can only prove lower
battles against non negative que juntos
so we'll start building until we get to
be able to prove lower balance against
all functions against any small family
of functions and then we'll be done ok
so the so the first let's the first
class I was sort of one extent to is
let's go from que juntos to sort of
things which are still very special but
depend on many more coordinates to enter
the point to hunters ok so the way we're
going to do that is a kind of a commonly
used method in things like this we're
going to take some graph G on n vertices
where n is much bigger than M so M is
think about Emma's being about root N
and then each of these functions is
n to the point to Hunter so you know
let's say this is the set that q1
depends on is to set the q2 q2 depends
on and so on okay so we have all these
sets that each Qi depends on and then
what we're going to do is just take this
hardon since g0 on em vertices and
randomly planted in this big end vertex
graph okay so I've you have to think
what that was a random planting g0 okay
so what do we expect what happened g0 is
sighs only root end so when we plant
randomly planted its intersection with
these hooter sets will become much
smaller in fact for any one of the sets
the intersection is slightly expected
intersection at size less than one okay
right because the probability for any
one of these influential coordinates and
and they said is only one of rude am and
they're only add to the point two of
them and so in fact the probability that
any fixed function has k coordinates in
there just take a Union bound I've
chosen the things correctly he's like n
to the minus K times ten to the minus
some constant times K which means that I
can actually do this for up to enter the
K function so if I set are to be and to
the point 3 k then I can actually find
the random restriction such that every
single one of the functions what only
depends on K coordinates in the random
restriction said no no this is perfect a
number around this K and the size is
entered the order of K so polynomial
size corresponds to constant number of
rounds you increase the source of the
graph the web ya know it's so many be
yes but that's a that didn't lose that
didn't lose your later there yeah this
is the there's a reason we only get n to
the log in it's not here this is this
step is this step is tight so I mean
this step is tied up to code to
polynomial factors but it's a but this
this is where I mean this is where the
connection between a number of rounds
and the size comes from it comes from
this part right here where now you see
that the you're looking at about n to
the K functions and you had k rounds of
shirley arms okay so so the point is
that an N by the way the grass outside
g0 is just disconnected or just wait 0
everywhere else there's nothing
interesting happening except in g0 and
now you can just you can basically just
transport this hyperplane down to
this you know 2 to the M dimensional
subspace on you and you approve a lower
bound against these functions and using
this graph okay so this this shows you
that if your functions are all into the
point two hunters then you can prove a
lower bound against them ok all right ok
so now how do we gather we reduce to the
case a 10 to the point two hunters so
the first thing we do is smooth out the
functions ok so here's this is the hyper
cube and think about all the all the
points X in the hypercube at which one
of these functions is big say at least r
squared ok so like so this is ok so
these are all sort of the bad parts of
the hypercube just by Marcos inequality
ok so i guess uh this is too much to go
too many clicks right I can know I mean
the not dilemmas are non-negative so i
can assume that the expectation of every
function is one say just by normalizing
it ok so let's assume that the
expectation of the functions are one
then just by Markov's inequality sort of
for any fixed function i can only have
you know i can only bigger than r
squared on one over R squared fraction
the hypercube so in fact by marcus
inequality the total measure of bad
points for any function is you know you
take their union is only one over R ok
so it's a small fraction of the cube so
the point is it I'll just make the
following promise I'm going to produce
this this separating hyperplane this
dysfunctional H at the end after I
produce it I'll just zero out H on these
few points ok and I am there night so
then I can ignore them and the reason
this works this is where we need use one
part of Travis functional is a it's a
fairly smooth functional it doesn't
depend too much on any one point so this
into the el infinito of the shrubs
functional is small this is actually a
very small amount of error zeroing out
on a small measure of points ok so
that's one will use it one more place
instead you get this but like you still
looking yeah the CMM proof no no so the
i'll do i'll do it if like in the
question period if you ask i'll write
down explicitly what is the functional
so now you can just see
then it's a but it doesn't it doesn't
use this is all sort of works for any
CSP so there's no we don't use the fact
that I mean obviously we need to use the
char karmakar check microchip bounds
eventually but we don't need to know
anything about how the gap instance is
constructed this is this is small just
by just really read it off from shali
items okay so now we have our functions
that satisfy this kind of Alan infinity
bounds now we want to prove some
structural fact about them we like to
prove that every such function is well
approximated by a hooter then then we'd
be done right because we proved lower
bounds against the end to the point two
hunters okay that's way too much to ask
but here's here's what one can prove and
the proof is very simple there exists
okay it's a k times log R times n to the
point to Hunter the K is something small
okay is even a constant for us okay so
basically and log R is also small so
really these things are much smaller
than to the point to you should focus on
n to the point to hear this is an end to
the point to who's the Q prime such that
every low degree fourier coefficient of
Q minus Q prime is small okay so q q
prime is a huntha that approximates q
although it approximates a little bitty
part of q okay and not in a particularly
strong way it's that you have a bound on
every fourier coefficient I mean note
that there are like a into the cave such
fourier coefficient so this is not such
a great great not okay so you might be
worried that you know you have this
approximation the high degree part of Q
minus Q prime could be something crazy
okay so here's what we use the fact that
we use another factor on this rally is
functional it's actually a degree K as a
multi linear polynomial over the
hypercube okay in some sense I Charlie
Adam's only needs to fool things that
look like integral distributions on
subsets of K vertices so sort of now you
use its power against it so if it can be
expressed with just the Greek a so it's
kind of like the lowly shirali Islands
functional is here and Q minus Q prime
could be quite large in the high degree
part but kind of
goes over his head right so sort of you
can basically basically the hide review
part of Q minus Q prime is orthogonal to
H so it just you don't care have any
band on it this was a more interesting
name when it was animated but I couldn't
do it okay all right way okay yeah so
that's the proof so let me just recap so
here here's the ears the basic idea
again we by zeroing out this whatever
function we get by zeroing it out we can
assume that all the functions are by
xoring out on some small measure the
space we can assume that all the
functions are bounded now every such
bounded function can be approximated by
an end to the point to hunta in the low
degree sense so the low degree part can
of Qi and Qi Prime are small then we do
this random restriction not every Qi
prime depending on n to the point two
coordinates but when we do this so if
when we randomly plant this graph g HQ y
prime only depends on cake coordinates
in G and then ok so now the Shah Abbas
functional can can fool these Qi primes
restricted to g0 because they're only
que juntos but now according to the
Charlie Evans functional it appears that
Qi and Qi prime are very close together
because they're there they're closing
the low degree sense and this functional
can only perceive low degree things
right so it's our thought not to all the
high degree part ok so that's was the
that's the end of the proof ok I don't
any questions ok so 85 if I have time
I'll say what's the function yeah so
this works for whatever values of cns to
sure all you get from Charlie Adam's so
for max cut the gap is between one and a
half from four three sides of gas
between one and seven eighths right I
mean it works for NEC cns you take a
charlie adams gapping since you get a
gap instance here
you only know that the video captions or
smoke and say well yeah okay so let's
just make sure to ask me that in a
second so I mean I'm ending quite early
so you just plenty of time so this is
this is the answer to this question is
why we think we cannot so for its first
Raleigh Adams you know that actually
there's a lower bound against n to the
epsilon rounds why can't we prove lower
button again sooo to the end to the
epsilon sighs in your programs it's
because of addressing this issue so
that's where the that's where the
problem comes okay so let me you know
maybe the even the most exciting part of
this is the future directions okay so
one of them is to handle this problem it
seems to be basically just a technical
weakness on our part that we cannot go
push it all the way to sort of that we
cannot get this dependent to hold for K
arbitrary we can only get this
connection build for caving about login
for up to login rounds and then
afterwards up proof breaks down but the
connection should keep holding it should
it should be that you can prove subjects
natural lower bounds against all of
these things as well not just super
polynomial there's a very interesting
question of whether this can be extended
beyond constraint satisfaction problems
like 2 tsp or two vertex cover so the
big thing we used about constraint
satisfaction is that the assignment
space is a product structure we can do
for you analysis there the second you go
to some other problems where you don't
have a product like take take the fact
that this you know the uniform
distribution on TSP boys on the complete
graph that's a very interesting
combinatorial object but it doesn't have
a product structure and so things like
kunta has to be defined more carefully
and it's not clear what happens okay can
this be use to saw resolve this original
problem of jana caucus on the on the
size of linear programs for the perfect
matching polytope so jana caucus prove
any any symmetric linear program for
perfect matching as exponential size but
generalizing is too arbitrary linear
programs has been open since his paper
no so they're they're thing only works
for TSP it doesn't work for perfect
matching
mumbai good yep none but for bipartite
graphs you have a lit up on Romeo size
if there's a flow relaxation right so
you can write as flow and you get
polynomial size their their their
technique actually proves that for
instance independent set cannot be
solved exactly with small linear
programs and then they use an NP
hardness reduction 2 TSP to get the
polytope 4 TSP so it does so it will not
work for matching but I mean shirali
atoms for matching is perfect matchings
is quite well understood so there's a
paper of climate ooh and Alistair which
shows which sort of analyze is very
tightly the gap for perfect matchings
all the way up to the maximum number of
rounds so you have sure all the atoms
gaps here the question is can you use
this technology to prove general oh no
and then of course after you see there's
some connection into linear programs and
charlie adams you want to do something
similar between semi-definite programs
and the lesser hierarchy in particular
the techniques for TSP the recent
techniques developed for TSP they cannot
work for semi definite programs because
as i said they're based on this sort of
basically one hard matrix and that
matrix is not hard for semi definite
programs okay whatever it it means it's
easy that matrix can be easily figured
out by semi definite programs so but but
this gives a path possibly a difficult
path to proving lower bounds against
arbitrary polynomial size semi definite
programs via the strong gas we know for
for Lasserre okay let me stop there
okay yeah so the so okay so the first
alchemist question was about so we only
know that that the we know that the the
grief k Fourier coefficients of the yeah
right so maybe I think I can answer
Alphonse question without doing any
thing and then I can so I'm going in the
sort of simplest to so so we know that
the Greek a Fourier coefficients of this
are at most n to the minus point 1 so
the immediate problem you have these are
n de menthe these are these are
functional n bits so they have n to the
K Fourier coefficients so if you put if
you just applied you know if you just
calculate the l2 bound this even the
load to be part of this could have a
huge help to ms that's problematic but
the the key is that we do this random
restriction to this set of size M so
actually only the Fourier coefficients
in EM are matter everything L outside
goes away because the functional only
depends on things in em so then you get
something which looks like em to the D
times n to the minus point 1 and now if
you choose these parameters
appropriately you can get this to go to
0 oh sorry okay okay okay is number of
rounds sorry case yes okay is the is the
is a degree so if we look at this thing
on we have only em to the K for your
coefficients and then we can just use
the easy bound here okay so now if you
choose you know ok m to the n to the 1
over k then you then this you can't you
can make this little of one
appropriately this is also in order for
this to be little old one you see that
this bound this means that you can only
go for about login / log log and rounds
before you before this guy's so sort of
like our inability to do something non
trivial here is what makes the number of
rounds stop okay okay and now Ryan's
question okay so what does for people
who maybe are not familiar what is sure
all the atoms do charlie adams just in
is that your linear programming solution
when you restrict it any set of K
variables the the induced solution on
those key variables can be written as a
convex combination of integral solutions
so it insists that every for every small
set of variables it look really looking
to grow so they're okay so there's a
different way you can you can you can do
this set up so you can you can think
about Charlie Adam's as giving you sort
of this pseudo expectation so basically
it has the ability on anything it yeah
just so you to operate just in the
description but what's the oh yeah all
the functional yeah let's ok who is what
we want to write down the functional now
ok so if you think about what this means
it means that for any function depends
only k coordinates I can talk about
averages of this function under this
purported distribution that the actually
it's a real distribution that Charlie
Adam's is giving me so this this gives
us a Billy this sort of this notation
came from this be and the who stole our
thoughts are on the paper see Joe Zee bz
with some authors in between yeah Brenda
herro a rock store and Owen calendar
yeah site so see it was bad with better
to do elements thing and just say be
busy for lizard okay so you can think
about this this kind of pseudo
expectation which to any function that
depends on li ke coordinates assigns a
value that's an average over some
distribution okay so this will be okay
so so based on its in it actually have
more than that you have the property
that if you look at any two of these
distributions and you look at what they
induce on the intersection of those
things and there's some consistency ok
so what it means that you can define
this this functional on so on degree at
most K multi linear polynomials so it's
a it's a linear functional
and it has the property that that the
expectation of a polynomial is very new
0 if P itself is very equal to 0 and
depends are only at most K coordinates
okay so you can you can think about all
such operators there they map degree K
multi linear problem as the real numbers
their linear functionals and and they
can prove that anything that depends on
li ke coordinates and is not negative is
actually not negative and then you can
think about the charlie adams value at
4k rounds on the graph G let's let's
just look at max cut so this is the
maximum over all such pseudo expectation
functionals of of the expected LP value
so for max cut it's like some I / j 1
minus pseudo expectation X I XJ over 2
so this is this is this is this is
equivalent to K rounds Australia items
you maximize over all of these pseudo
expectations of just the pseudo
expectation of the objective value okay
so now what is the functional the
functional is just is just this summer
also to the size K look at the okay
where the Chi alphas are the 48 basis so
this is the functional
it's a okay and and the one and the el
caso so and the point is that all right
let's let's do the let's see one thing
so okay what is this this functional
depends on only I mean it's only the
Greek a so it satisfies one of the
properties i said I there each of the
Fourier coefficients at most one because
it's just some pseudo expectation of
something that depends are only k
variables well okay yeah in the each of
the four equations at most one so in
particular the ellen fein over this
function is at most M to the K right
this is not the greatest bound on
infinite norm but you know we're
throwing seems none anyway so the one
thing you might want to see is why does
this thing full Hunter's okay and the
reason is just because if i take any if
q is a que hunter then the inner product
of h and q is just equal q is a
non-negative came on to the enterprise
like an ancient q is just equal to some
expectation over a real distribution of
of Q which is obviously a great angle to
zero because Q is are non-negative cute
non-negative value so the point is that
the inner product for any function thing
only k coordinates the inner product
with H is some expectation over the
input bits and so it's always
non-negative yeah so this this gives you
the property that for any Calhoun so you
have this non-negative inner product and
now if you look at the you know if so
now look at the cout function if you if
you if shirali Adams claims it has an LP
value which is bigger than C then okay
you need this is the
okay and you need to just notice that
this is it is this is do this is the
suit this is the expectation of a
constant which is a constant that's good
so if if Cheryl Adams claims that the
value is bigger than C then this is less
than zero and for every hunter is very
good 0 so that gives you your separating
functional for hunters and then you can
follow through
the smell realize that the cmn lower
balance for sure Ali items for cut stop
it like n to the epsilon I think it's
possible that look like real and rounds
of Charlie Adam's you can be enough it's
a good question uh maybe I know I just
it just happens that that Luca actually
has some the algorithm that can do this
on let's see i'll tell you the it seems
that Rudin might be the right to right
value like it's seen you see it seems
possible you could do it with rude and
rounds that you could get something
better than half vs. one I can tell you
why I flying but it's birthday paradox